read Ryan he is the team president of
the Houston Astros and obviously that
franchise in that City have had a lot to
deal with over the last week or so Reid
its Ross Tucker filling in for Dan here
today on a Thursday edition of the Dan
Patrick show really appreciate your time
obviously well as we look at the
pictures and videos up here in the
Northeast and everywhere in the country
we're thinking about you guys what
what's it like down there what's it
really like I mean we see the videos and
pictures but what are you and the team
experiencing yeah Ross thanks for having
me on the best thing I can say is it's
surreal you know there are pockets of
town that have had complete devastation
other pockets of town that never lost
power and when you have 52 inches of
rain over basically a five-day period we
did not sustain the major wind damage
that a hurricane normally brings because
it hit south of town but because it's
stalled it just you know dumped the most
rain in the history of America I think
it's it's Katrina and Sandy you know and
still double that everything was flooded
roads were flooded houses were flooded
and you know the water damage it goes
wherever it will go and there's loss of
life and destruction of property but
other spots people weren't even touched
so it's very very surreal and for our
guys Ross it's been tough because
they've left to go to California
thinking this was going to be a tropical
storm and by the time they finished up
the angel series it was a stage three
for hurricane that was affecting their
families in their community so it's been
very very tough what has been the impact
on the team the players the employees I
don't know where they all live in the
city but how hard were their homes hit
and how much of an impact has it had on
those guys well I think it had an impact
on the team there's no doubt I've talked
to AJ every day I've been here the
entire time in the city of course we we
stopped in Dallas for a night and
we went on to Tampa we decided to go to
Tampa because we have another series the
Mets that we're actually gonna play this
weekend but at the time we didn't know
where we were going and what was going
to happen and so we ended up going to
Tampa and so for guys that packed for a
three-day road trip the reality of a you
know 18 game road trip and the fact that
their families were displaced and they
couldn't get ahold of them
it had an emotional toll and I think
it's showed in the way we've played the
last couple days but we got a bit of
good news that the mayor really wanted
us to play here in Houston this weekend
mayor Sylvester Turner his leadership
ceman phenomenal minute maid park was
unscathed we had a little bit of water
damage but it was in the lower bowels of
the stadium and nothing anywhere that
could keep us from playing and so
yesterday we announced that we're going
to play the Mets this weekend a
doubleheader on Saturday and one game on
Sunday here at Minute Maid and it has
brought a ray of sunshine to the city
had tremendous outpouring of support
people excited that we're going to be
playing because folks want a distraction
and they want to get back to normal and
I think we're gonna help do that on
Saturday we're talking with Reed Ryan
he's the team president of the Houston
Astros they obviously have played
recently down in Tampa against the
Rangers because they've been displaced
by Hurricane Harvey you know I guess my
question is Reed you know I'm an NFL guy
and I saw that the Cowboys and the
Texans canceled that game so that in
part the Texans players could get back
to Houston and help their families help
everything going on there in the city
was that a conversation I know that's a
preseason game but was that a
conversation at all at the major league
baseball level about you know letting
the guys come back so they can make sure
that their their families and everything
was safe we did in fact we were
scheduled to play Friday and so our team
will be coming back today after the game
we play at 1:00 Eastern today and Tampa
so our guys will be back here in Houston
tonight they you know not all of them
they are married not all of them you
know families are here
and so they want to help out just like
the Texans are doing so what we're going
to do this weekend tomorrow we are going
to take members of the team and right
next door to us here at Minute Maid is
our Convention Center and we have about
10,000 of acuities there and we are
taking all of the promotion items from
the game this weekend Saturday was
supposed to be a Korea Carlos Correia
Jersey giveaway we're going to go
deliver those to the folks that are at
the Georgia Brown Convention Center
we're also going to be delivering
tickets to all of those folks and we're
going to invite them out to come to
games this weekend we want them to be
able to get out of that Convention
Center because many of them have been on
a cot for four or five days with only
the shirt on their back and so we're
going to give them some clothes we're
going to donate a bunch of other
t-shirts we're going to get them out to
the game and even for a couple hours of
it is an escape from what they've been
dealing with and we feel like we will
have brought some good to the city of
Houston so you know we looked at this
decision Ross a lot of different ways
from your municipal perspective with the
mayor and the police chief and we just
felt like it was the right thing to do
and so we decided we were going to do it
I know it's secondary read but how
concerned are you about the impact that
this could have on the team moving for
me you guys are in first place you're
having an unbelievable year your World
Series contenders how how much of a
concern is it that this could have a
lasting impact that really you know
affects what's been a tremendous season
so far that's a great question and it's
it's been floating around town I think
our guys getting home when you see the
images on TV you're only seeing the
worst of the worst and I think guys need
to go check on their own property their
own neighbors their own families once
they do that and I really believe that
this weekend is going to be a weekend of
healing that when people come out to the
game and our players are connecting with
with whether it's a vacuous or just
people that have been cooped up in their
house for four or five days and want to
get out you know gas stations don't have
gas there's a lot of stores and
restaurants that are not open every day
this week they
and coming back more and more and we
know by Saturday that you know we're
gonna really be back to normal so I'm
hoping it doesn't have an effect but I
think the biggest thing that hurt us the
second half of the season and we've
really been a 500 ballclub this has been
we haven't had all our guys you know
Gatos has been out McCann's been out
they're back now
McCullers history have assignment last
night he'll be coming back Carlos
Correia obviously who's you know the big
the big stick in the middle of the
lineup has been gone the second half of
the season he's going to be coming back
and so we've not been healthy and I
think getting through this weekend
organized getting home expanding the
rosters tomorrow and getting all of our
you know core players back I think we're
going to be positioned for run late
September or early October and hopefully
in late in October Reed really
appreciate the time good luck to you
guys in every way moving forward yeah
last thing I'd like to say Ross is we
have set up a site a you caring site
it's why oh you caring you caring
dot-com back slash Astros Harvey if
anybody wants to donate our owner Jim
crane kicked it off with four million
dollars Major League Baseball the
Players Association donated a million
you've seen what JJ Watt been doing all
of the teams in baseball have been
reaching out to me the Angels Rangers
the Cardinals the Royals people were
sending money players are sending money
and so if you want to help out these
folks are going to have a long road as
they rebuild their houses in their lives
we would appreciate the help and we we
look at our role in this is putting a
positive spotlight on the city of
Houston and raising awareness for the
flood campaign and what's the website
one last time read it is you caring why
oh you CA are ing caring calm you caring
calm back slash Astros Harvey that's
awesome read thanks so much man good
luck okay thank you
alright there he is Reed Ryan the team
president of the Houston Astros the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience